[Music]
Okay. So, my name is Itar Friedman, CEO
and co-founder of Codto and I'm going to
talk about yeah vibe coding but more on
the confidence part and why this is
maybe surprising why CLI might be the
new interface leader for that. uh and uh
we are soft launching a CLI tool uh
right now five minutes ago. So you can
go so you can go and install it uh soft
launch play with it give us feedback uh
there is some capacity and uh in order
to verify like who is in the audience
just like if you can tell me if you
tried cloud code or codci
okay and I guess if I ask about aides
you would also also do that right and
the question is why and I'm going to
talk about it a bit okay
uh so the agenda is that I'm actually
going to do really zoom out to the gen
3.0. What do I mean by that? And from
the autocomplete to the multi- aent
workflow and workflows, you see it's a
theme that we're returning here CLI is
something that can support that. Uh and
how do we believe at Kodto is going to
be the real shift in software
development and uh like why is the CLI
is the future in you know being able to
do vibe coding with confidence and
eventually I'm going to connect do zoom
out again. And I'm going to zoom in zoom
out even with a demo uh and connect the
dots and I will uh say what explain a
bit what is cod. I didn't do it right
now and we'll do it a bit a bit later
but that's something I'm going to cover
shortly. So AI for developers and I just
think that most of people here are
developers according to the amount of
hands that were raised. So I think like
we first got some tools that we liked AI
tools then we got some tools that we
loved and I'm not that sure that we
actually uh get tools into our hands
that completely u be become a gamecher
for us. Okay, my it's maybe unpopular
opinion. I'm going to elaborate a bit.
So, in order to do that, I'm going to
differentiate developers between noobs
and enterprise. It's a bit weird like
it's not necessarily juniors like they
are juniors in enterprise, right? But
still, you know, like let's let's use
that for for a second. Noobs versus
enterprise. So, I think Gen 1.0 uh was
the autocomplete moment, right? We
started being able to generate uh
writing our our our code and getting a
few lines ahead of us. We really like
that if you weren't a developer like you
couldn't really do more right so you
needed to be a developer already and
then came uh the gen 2.0 Oh, the chat,
diagentic chat. And I think like we saw
even junior developers generating much
more lines of code. Uh maybe the seniors
or the enterprise liked it but also had
a lot of problems with it. They need to
review much more code, not necessarily
high quality code. I hear that a lot and
I'm going to show you like uh 500 tweets
uh about it. Not really, but but from
some opinion leaders. And I think that
the game changer moment is when we will
move from chatic chat to actually being
able to uh and it's a spoiler command
command line interface to give commands
to to our agents as if they're like team
members and they do end toend flow. What
is an end toend flow is something I'm
going to talk about a bit. Uh and I
think like you will see different
players and in different parts of of
this map like I mean different tools.
Let's let's think about it again. So I
think like in the in the autocomplete
moment, we saw first ID plugins. Again,
it's not a game changer. I'm just like
going to complete more lines of code uh
uh for you. Uh we liked it. And then uh
let's rethink how we do coding inside
ID. So we saw ID forks. And then what's
the third wave? Sometimes I hear uh
forking people. I didn't say that. What
I think it actually we're going to see
is like I AI across the SLC. Okay. like
being able to do end to end to end uh
flows that are specific closing a task
that is specific in the SDLC but more
importantly using AI across the SDLC
again not and not only in the ID hence
how do we do that command line right
it's one of those tools um a lot of
spoilers so I think uh when we had aha
moment with the uh with autocomplete the
next aha moment was you know all the
hype around vibe coding and I'm going to
touch about that and I think the next
like thing that I think we're going to
hear about is like hey I'm really doing
100x choose choose a number 10x 50x 100x
development and I I'm doing that with
confidence not just like vibing through
it I think that that will be a gamecher
uh uh moment uh for for us it means that
we totally broke the way the way we work
we're going to get to that so I think
like I I differentiated between I
separated between noobs and enterprise
for example I think for noobs it mean
end to end means for example that you
prompt and get a software a fully
managed software for you right we I I
guess we're all playing it with even if
you're a developer you're doing some
POVs or some site or being able to do
some simple games but then in the
enterprise setup in the heavy duty setup
then basically what means for us like AI
cross this you'll see is reliable
versatile workflows and when I say
workflows we had a few sessions amazing
sessions I'm actually like combining
them and which is one of one of the
points that were made there like uh uh I
think uh child makes made a made a point
where an agent is creating workflows and
calling them and then there was a
discussion about like workflows and you
know using agent etc. So I when I say
workflows I already mean agentic
workflow that's let's let's let's move
on like workflow agent who cares like uh
like uh so it's going to be combined and
and I think like in order to do that
with trust uh you need to be able more
importantly is to have workflows or
agents that are related to trust for
example having really high quality
reviewing capabilities really high
quality testing capabilities being able
to do a variety of jobs to be done that
we do as developers end to endish and
and high quality. So that will be a game
changer. Let's be a bit bit more
specific as as developers. Uh we do a
lot of things and not just write code. I
took like four parts which is like I
think less than a half of what we do and
and I and I think like basically vibe
coding was very focused on let's like do
initial planning and and and write code
fast like and you know vibe whatever we
get like that implementation or that we
feel it and and move on. But actually in
heavy duty software we need to do many
other things. We need to do for example
uh bug fixing or we need to do
refactoring and changing features etc.
We want to move fast without breaking
things. So I think we need to have not
the the testing and the writing as a uh
a handsite which you can do like testing
and and reviewing inside ID tools that
are very mature but not as a handsite
but rather like really being the the red
team right thinking as a as a tech lead
that is reviewing code and and having
like fitting technology uh uh for that.
So if we are able to to put like AI in
each one of those like parts maybe then
it will be a gamecher but I think even
then like we already have tools for for
code review for testing shameless plug
we're going to talk about later that's
what we do at KOD we focus being more on
the red team even though we have tools
for the blue we focus more on the red
team still I don't think it's a gamecher
okay and I think like a first like a
feeling of a game changanger as I
mentioned not only putting AI across to
CLC but having workflows across parts of
the SDLC. So one semi gamecher could be
like if we manage to shift left the
review and the testing is as you write
code then you also get those suggestion
and get high quality code uh uh that is
already according to your company best
practices and you don't need to wait for
the AI review tool to tell you that only
after you pushed it right but I think
like uh I think we we have even a better
way to do that a bit more agentic so
let's an reanalyze the these four blocks
these four tasks
So uh I instead of having one like the
x-axis now there's also y-axis it's
executed
or whatever where you're searching now
chatgpt vshape software development
y-axis executability uh x-axis time so
we start with planning it's not
executable then we write code in most
cases you're not doing admit it like a
TDD okay so you write you write your
code and then you write your test uh and
in most cases and that's executable but
it's not application code so So it's a
bit higher and then and then you do the
review. A game changer is like when we
actually manage to take that V and
squeeze it and and have like different
workflows and agents talking to each
other. And that's why like I had the
word MCP and A2A and I'm going to get to
that later. I I I I'm guess if you're in
this conference, you know what I'm
talking about that where maybe there's
different agents that are talking to
each other. Maybe it's one agent using
tools that are able to connect all of
these like all at once. That that will
be a gamecher. So to and to some extent
what it means is that that uh like the
game changer moment is when we're
looking all of these steps like
rigorously and in one holistic uh uh
solution if you like uh cloud is is
mature for 10 years and then whiz came
and said we can't put an a security
application for each part of the cloud
like or each uh uh necessity of of
security. Let's build one holistic uh
solution for for for cloud security. the
same thing will happen to us in the
gamechanging moment for for intelligent
software development. Zooming out back
again to vibe coding with confidence. Uh
it it didn't happen a long time ago when
Karpati and uh wrote about vibe coding
like you really like I thought it like a
decade already in AI uh years. uh and
and the interesting thing it didn't take
too much time like a month or two uh
where where we started where where we
started seeing push backs right this is
not me by the way uh and and uh and and
actually just a few weeks ago the same
karpati came back and rethought vibe
coding notice what he's saying like code
I actually and professionally care about
contrast vibe code the same karpati okay
and it's really interesting I think to
analyze what he's saying the first thing
He's saying okay code that I care about
probably heavy duty software or I like
the quality it's maintainable like we
I'm going to get to that and then he's
he tries to offer solution I love him I
I mean I never met him but but uh we all
saw his videos right like 15 years ago
10 years ago so uh he's giving solution
not only like uh like being annoying
like okay no I said v coding no v coding
anymore so first he's saying the first
number one is is context he's saying
like bring context
here he's saying doing it manual But
that's not game changer if now I need to
start bringing it manually. And then
he's giving also two three four five six
seven like this this is a workflow. He's
actually suggesting a workflow. That's
one of the topics of the three talks
that we had now. Okay. So now uh like
this is really important I think like
how do you vibe code with confidence?
You need to like you said like just vibe
coding probably you don't care about
qual quality. You do care. You need to
bring the right context and have
workflows and these workflows can be
connected to agent could be part of the
agent could be part of your flows and
that's like in the nine minutes or so
some some of thing I'm going to talk
about karpati and others are not the
only one this is just like from a week
ago if you you know this a very great
great person great material he's saying
like AI coding tools are so much less
useful on existing large code bases okay
he he's saying that and and is this is
differently than compared green green
field work and it's not surprising
because if you have a green field work
or it's a simple software code
generation is all you need okay like
it's magnificent the tip of the iceberg
give a prompt you get your software but
when you're talking about enterprise
heavy duty software then there's much
more than that we all know it right
there is a maintainability testing
reviewing etc and shameless plug well I
am the CEO codto I have to say we are
looking at that as a holistic like how
can we really bring a gamecher moment is
if we look at all of this at a holistic
approach that's why uh we have a multi-
aent uh architecture I am not going to
go over it one by one because there's
one specific thing that I wanted to show
so we have uh a tool we have a agent
that is focused on let's call it deep
research deep ask in code and and then
uh we have a tool that is specific
that's our flagship for for code review
called code emerge And then finally we
have uh like a tool that is inside
ideides that enable to shift left like
bring that context bring that uh bring
that best best practices that were
collected over time. The codto merge
tool, the code review tool collects best
practices over time and this the context
that is coming from the codto aware and
the best practices coming for codmerge
helping you rather whatever code
generation tool you're using or using
directly codto tool to make sure that
that's in high quality but recently like
20 minutes ago uh we released also a a
CLI tool and that is meant to help you
with the workflow parts. The workflow is
already integrated into our solution.
But this like really uh or workflow and
on steroids. There's another thing very
important that is coming out in two
months and stay tuned follow us whatever
any platform that that you want. I kind
of like uh didn't want to show it right
now. So CLI tool why I hope like I gave
enough like hints um and so far and the
main reason is putting AI to work across
the CLC and I remind you that starting
five minutes ago you can go download it
and play with it. It's a soft launch uh
we're going to announce about it more
deeply like in in in a couple of weeks.
So interestingly who who saw Simon's
like uh talk like he's magnificent. Some
people didn't. Okay. So, please go uh go
out of the room, I mean, and uh and then
come back after and watch uh online
later. And it's amazing like when he
wanted to demonstrate something, did he
open like one of the IDEs? He did not.
Like everything he did was with with a
CLI tool. Like that's if you are a
developer like that's idea that you can
run it in the background, you can run it
in different workflows. You can make
workflows. That's part of what I'm what
I'm going to show you. And and basically
with with Kodto uh the CLI tool which is
live uh live here then I can for example
chat with it and very interestingly that
is very quite like there are a few tools
that we talked about before that you can
do that but interestingly you can call
agents for example I can call the the
explain agent it's a dedicated agent uh
due to lack of time I'm not going to
show that I'm going to show something
else. So how does how did we made this
explain agent? You can actually with
Kodo the agent you can make other agents
and soon I'm going to show you how you
also create workflows and things like
that. So basically I can go and ask it
if the internet works uh well enough. Uh
you can go and ask it please create an
agent with this goal and and by the way
you can uh uh like give much more
information than what I'm doing right
now. I'm asking for it to create a
review agent. Okay, if Thunder works,
it's it's going to start working. It's
initializing MCP is going to search what
it can do, what it cannot do. And it now
it's it's going to work for for a few
minutes. Okay, like if I would ask you
to do it, you would do it take two
hours. So, let's give it two minutes.
Meanwhile, I'm going to to progress and
and uh and and tell you that that I
think one of the interesting things uh
about it, it's it's working. So one uh
most agents like I can't think of of one
that won't would have tools uh for
example the codto cover agent uh by the
way we have an open source for codto
cover uh it's a tool that automatically
uh generates coverage coverage uh it
increases the coverage automatically
increases coverage but you don't need
anymore to go download this open source
etc you just get it as part of the uh as
one of the agent
Okay. So, uh but if you do want to play
with the open source, etc. It's it's
it's fully open source. Okay. Back back
to my point. I can go and call cover
which uses different tools. For example,
it uses tools related to coverage
reports and and you I can look what I
can do in a command line. I can tell it
dump all the logs somewhere, right? How
do you do that with an ID plugin? You
can, but you need to hack it. Hack it.
But the interesting thing, what can we
do with command lines? And many here are
are developers. You can pipe you can
pipe uh uh tools together agents you can
pipe like uh uh uh workflows etc. So I
want to run code of code generating code
and then I want to run the cover that
like you know increase the coverage
testing maybe the code will generate a
few tests but I have an agent that is
specializing in increasing coverage and
then I want a review agent that is now
cooking and finished. Uh um and I'll go
back to it in a minute if I have time.
Now this is not no agent to engine
communication. I did a pipeline that
just passed a result. But what if we can
and and before I exemplified with MCP
but what if we can invent a command line
for A2A. So those agents are will run in
parallel as you go and they will have
some communication uh between them. So I
actually have to say that yesterday we
had like a 20 uh 50 uh like people like
like those that you had we the speakers
and I asked who is using A2A no one is
using it so it's still way to go but
this is an example oh yes come talk to
me later so I'll know one person okay
thank you so uh and then I'll edit all
the posts I know one person and and uh
and and but but we're getting there okay
this is an example you need multiple
agents you need A2A Okay, you you would
want to use it if you want discover
discoverability between agents or
handshakes. So this is a good example if
you have many agents and you can run
them in the background etc. So in this
case the agent finished and I have the
definition uh I have the definition of
the of the agent uh over over here. Uh
it's called merge agent and you can see
like like all everything the
instructions that was made for it uh
like what tools it is is using uh I'm
going to add one that uh sometime I want
to be very clear it's there and by the
way it also has like a output scheme.
I'm going to remove that remove that for
a second. Okay. And then I can go back
uh and and just call it it was called
merge review uh codto merge uh review
agent that was just generated a minute
ago and it will review. I didn't give it
any you see that there's a parameter
automatically created like uh uh uh that
that uh uh I I can tell it what to
review etc give instruction it's very
flexible but I didn't okay so uh I'm
almost stack of time so I won't uh show
you but what I just will tell you that
basically I can tell it to use best
practices from the organization
important for vibe coding with
confidence and I can also tell it to
have some success or or or failure
criteria to know that something happen
well or not. For example, if it managed
to get some coverage, okay, that's how
you work with with confidence. Um, yeah,
and you can connect things to
pre-commit, postcommit. Okay, everything
you can do, you can do automatically.
Very interestingly, and and with that
almost reached the end, very very
interestingly, you can say the CLI tool
is very lame.
But notice, did you notice what what
Simon did? He used the CLI but
eventually checking content he he used
different interfaces. So you can from
the CLI itself automatically generate
interfaces that are fitting for your
task. And one of those for example is an
interface for for code review. So who
cares anymore about IDES when you can
have flexible IDs. And with that, I'll
finish and I'll just tell you that I
think we're going into a future where
we're going to have swarm of agents,
each one specializing and having
different credential, different uh best
best practices, etc. And uh and and and
it's coming really fast, 2025, 2026.
Thank you.
[Music]